want to know what heating up in theaters  this weekend the fate of the universe  lies in your shoulders so what came in  the galaxy again the team is back for  more space action in guardians of the  galaxy vol 2  Uncas no why can't you just be a person  because she's not a lousy mom she's a  boy in three generations a young woman's  decision forces a family to come  together something's got to change  I'm done with being an exception  everybody knows I'm an idiot all right  tough guy I'm a [ __ ] Debra Winger stars  in the lovers about a married couple  falling in love right before their  divorce so you're screwing your wife now  as if see with hot in theaters with this  week's anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]